ονομισμάτο είναι σε ηλεκτροντικά πρτοφολια δηλαδή δεν υπάρχει κάτι το συγκεκριμένω δεν υπάρχει ς αρεθμός
ο λογαριασμού σε μια ντράπεζα όπως γίνετον παρθο παρεθόν οι απάτες διαδικτύου που μπορούσε να
πάμε στην τράπεζα και νωπούμε δώστε μου κατάσταση πιώσουμε ο δικαιούχος καιο λιπάκαι λοιπά τώρα
προσπαθούμε να ακολουθήσουμε την μποργά το χρημά των μέσω των κρυπτων νομισμάτων και διασπούνται ξανά
και ξανά και εξανά καισε πάρα πολλές σε πάρω απολλά λλά λεκτρονικά πορωτοφωλια έχουμε εντιπητυχίες
έχουμε αρκετές επιτυίες έχουμε σμεύσει αρκετάρχτηματικά πό ένα σταση άλλι στην ιστο μιυαλώντων περισσότερο είναι
ικόνα ότι οχάκε είναι ένα πο κάθετις ένα σκοτεινό δωμάτιο εκάτες υκολογιστές με την κουκύλα
στο κεφάλι και πλοκάνη λογαριασμός είναι αυτή οικόνα ή πλέον έχουμε ξεφύγια από τα έργατα
και εμογραφικά και μπορεί να είναι το άτομο που μένι δίπλαμας ττων που δεν είναι
δίπλαμας όσ αλλά θα τηλέγω τη καταγάποιο τροπο γίναι σανβύο μιχανοποίησει όλων αυτώνται ενεαργιν μάλιστα
είναι ένα γραφείουν κάθεται κάποιος καθοδιγούμενως από τον από τον πυπέρθυ νοτις να α υπεριπτώσει
να το πούμε αν μπορούμε να πο κατέτοιο αναχωρεί και κάθεται επόμενος αδί υπάρχει θα
αρθμόςφαγέλλων που διαχειρίζονται οι εμπληματίς σα λέω αυτό υπάρχει πολύ συστηματικά στης χώρες της βσίας
έχουμ καταλίξει σε διάφορα πρόσωπα έχουμε εντάλματα σύλληψης υναντίων κάποιον προσώπο αέληνο κύπριος όχι όχι
είναι όλη ξένι έχουμε όμως ελλινοκύπριος που έφτασαν πληροφορίες κοντά σας ότι συνεργάζονται με τέτοιες
εταιρίες συνεργάζονται με τέτοιαάτομα όχι όχ είμαστες ευτυχής υπήρχει μια περιπτωσή παλύαα θυματτε